so i am a huge fan of house mark i've
loved their games over the years but to
be honest i did not love returnal when i
first started playing now with that
being said i have since went back to the
game and to be totally honest with you
guys i have truly fell in love with it
it is finally clicked for me and it's
certainly one of the best games i've
played this year and really a standout
on the ps5 which i know that's what the
review said at the time but as i've
gotten older i just don't have as much
time to immediately sink into games
right when they come out and beat them
very quickly like i used to by the way
people of the internet if you are new
here i'm retrorecontour and i'm just a
dad who loves games and the stories they
tell we post videos every week here on
youtube and today we are talking all
about returnal and my experience so far
of thinking that i kind of liked it too
i don't really like this game too
absolutely loving this game so today i
kind of just want to walk you through my
story with the game so far and what my
experience has been like and then if any
of you are kind of still on the fence
about the game or maybe you tried it and
didn't love it and you kind of wondered
should i pick it back up maybe this will
help you decide whether or not you
should and this is some footage straight
from my ps5 a lot of what you're seeing
here is going to be the second biome
there's not going to be any boss
spoilers but there will be spoilers for
various parts of the level so if you
don't want to see anything at all then
you might just want to listen but there
will be no major spoilers in this video
so as i mentioned in the opening i've
been a pretty big fan of house mart for
a while now i absolutely loved rezo gun
it was my most played game on the ps4 at
launch like i just played a ton of rezzo
gun and for a while my claim to fame is
i was actually top 10 in the high scores
on rezo gun that's how much i got into
it and if you haven't played resogun
before it's not really a top down
shooter it's more kind of like a shooter
from the side i'm not even really sure
what the correct technical name for it
is but it's like that old school classic
arcade style of game where you're really
just playing for high scores yes you can
beat the game but after that after you
beat the game it's all about trying to
perfect your run and master it i enjoyed
super stardust enjoyed dead nation
enjoyed outland several of their other
games as well but by far the one that
really stood out for me was rezo gun so
being such a huge fan of house mark i
absolutely knew i was going to play
return on knew i was going to purchase
it for ps5 and was really excited about
this change for them because they
actually put out an article i can't
remember if it was like a blog post or
what it was but house mark put out a
piece basically telling everyone that
they felt arcade was dead and as a
result of that they were going to have
to shift and the types of games they
make were going to have to change in
order for them to survive and i really
thought it was a fascinating piece
because even me as someone who had
played all of their games or almost all
their games rather i could see that they
were never super popular and despite me
loving them so much and recognizing the
immense quality of the gameplay because
trust me guys if you haven't had a
chance to play some of their older games
definitely look back through their
library and give some of them a shot
because the gameplay which at the end of
the day that's really what it's all
about right even when they weren't so
worried about story or anything like
that the gameplay was top notch so i
knew going in that return would
absolutely have top-notch gameplay even
though it was a shift it was going third
person it wasn't that side-scrolling or
a top-down shooter anymore i got it on
launch day actually streamed it a little
bit i've even posted some videos here on
the channel about it and while i enjoyed
it like it just didn't click for me i i
saw the signs i saw little glimpses of
oh i can see house mark's dna in this i
made a video of how i thought it really
compared to metroid especially metroid
prime and when it first launched there
was a lot of talk around the game's
difficulty and i certainly thought it
was a difficult game but to the age i'm
at right now with working on a youtube
channel having a wife kids full-time job
all that stuff i'm really not so
concerned with difficulty as i am
concerned with how a game respects your
time and at least early on i honestly
didn't feel like it was very respectful
of my time because you would just you
know go so far and spend a couple of
hours playing only to have your progress
instantly reset the moment that you die
i mean everything goes back to the
beginning and this is coming from
someone who is a huge fan of the souls
games i've platinum bloodborne i i know
that formula and i'm totally okay with
having to play and learn and get better
and get better and get better or get
good as they say right but for whatever
reason i just was not digging the
gameplay loop of return and keep in mind
this is all taking place in the first
level i never made it outside of the
first level i shouldn't say never
eventually i did make it to the first
boss and i think i beat him on the third
try maybe but after i beat him i kind of
just like like put the game down and
didn't touch it for a while well here in
recent weeks i actually don't even know
what made me decide to pick it up and
start playing again but i saw it in my
ps5 across the menu bar there i was like
you know what let's jump back into
eternal and as i made my way through the
second biome and died and had to go back
through the first biome again it started
to click with me and i started to learn
things i started to pick up on things
that i had missed before and so where
before i thought you know what this game
isn't being very respectful of my time
by the fact that all my progress is
reset instead what i started to see is
no i've been focusing on the wrong
things things that i thought were
important maybe weren't as important as
i first thought because just to give you
an example when i first started out the
game and i think this is how most people
would start out the game you know i'm
going through every single room i'm
opening each chest that i can i'm trying
to kill all the enemies i'm grabbing
every item i'm trying to figure out what
the items even do i'm not really sure
what the best weapons are there are so
many little components of return on
where you're just like how does this
even fit together i don't even know what
this thing does and on a lot of these
things it intentionally does not tell
you there's also a lot of risk reward
with a lot of the choices that you make
and when i say choices i am speaking
strictly in terms of gameplay choices
although this certainly has more of a
story than past house mart games the
choices i'm talking about are not
related to the story at all so i just
don't want you to get the wrong idea
there and there was just something about
when i made it to the end of that second
biome and i finally beat that second
biome boss that i really started to see
even more of that house mark dna and
rather than seeing this as like a third
person action game
suddenly i started to see it as more of
that classic house mark style of trying
to perfect your run trying to make each
run as good as you can possibly make it
and being able to recognize sometimes
early on that you know what this isn't
working out i don't have the right
materials that i need i may even need to
just completely reset this run and as
far as where i'm at now i'm actually in
the third biome now just last night i
made it to the boss third biome by far
my favorite one so far absolutely loving
this one i really should have beaten the
boss but by the time i got to him my
health was so low and i actually didn't
have any healing items at all so i was
kind of like well you know what i'm
gonna go in here and we're just gonna
try this and i think i got a pretty good
handle of how he works and what weapons
might be good for him so next time i'm
already feeling confident about going in
to that fight and it's just such a stark
contrast of when i started the game and
i would die and i felt like i lost so
much progress even though i lost a lot
of the things that i had gained
throughout and not to give away too much
but there are some things that you get
to keep you don't get to keep most of
the things but there are a few key items
along the way as you make it to
different biomes that you will get to
keep but all that being said early on
when i would die after a two plus hour
run it just felt so agonizing this even
though i put a lot of time into it last
night i don't feel that way at all in
fact i'm really looking forward to
jumping back in because of how much i
learned on the last run and how i think
it's gonna help me make an even better
run this next time and that right there
is really for me the gameplay loop of
returnal and what makes it so compelling
and so strong yeah the story is
interesting honestly for me like the
story that i could do without it it's
fine you know it's like an interesting
story i'm kind of curious to see where
it goes at the end but for me it's that
gameplay loop of going into this
completely reorganized area which by the
way it does seem to be randomly
generated there are times where you'll
go in and you'll recognize certain parts
of the level like oh yeah i remember
this but it'll be in a different spot
than how it was before so even when you
go into a room that's completely new
because of the knowledge that you've
gained on past runs and because of your
understanding of the game you feel way
more confident going in i know it sounds
weird it sounds cliche like come on
right like the knowledge gained it's
like no i want items i want upgrades but
it's hard to explain it really is that
knowledge that you get by playing the
game to where you feel truly confident
going in this next time like oh dude i'm
going to absolutely crush this level
this time i've got all the information i
need if i can get a few good drops in
terms of items in terms of weapons we
are going to be set so actually i
haven't beaten the game yet i can't wait
to possibly do another one of these
videos after i've beaten it but i just
wanted to make this one now to kind of
let you guys know where my thoughts are
there may be some others out there who
are kind of on the fence who put the
game away and are like i don't really
get it it got crazy high review scores
and you haven't went back to it i would
say go back to return give it another
shot at least get through the second
biome and then see if things start to
click a little bit more for you they
certainly have for me and i'm really
having a blast with it as always guys
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon